Hello everyone today, we're going to talk about a fascinating topic.
Albinos albinos are humans or other living things that lack
pigmentation or coloration in humans.
This results in white hair and very light skin.
That's highly sensitive to sunlight.
Yeah. What is it?
[inaudible].
Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to talk about a language whose relationship to other modern
languages is not exactly known that language is Albanian
or ship as it's called an Albanian.
Albanian is an Indo-European language.
You may be wondering which branch of Indo-European is it a romance language,
a Slavic language, a Germanic language. How about a Celtic language,
a Hellenic language? Nope.
Albanian is a language isolate within the Indo-European language family,
meaning that it forms its own branch of Indo-European to which no other modern
languages belong.
The most common theory among scholars is that Albanian developed from the
ancient Elyria and language,
which itself was an Indo-European language with uncertain connections to other
ones. But there are others who think it's related to Thracian or dation.
Albanian is spoken by around 7.6 million people,
mainly in the Balkin region of Southeastern Europe.
It's the official language of Albania as well as Kosovo,
along with Serbian in North Macedonia, alongside Macedonian.
And it's also official at the municipal level in six of Montenegro's 24
municipalities. It's also spoken by minorities in other adjacent areas,
such as Serbia, Italy and Greece,
not much is known about the history of Albanian.
And that's partly because the earliest examples of Albanian writing that we know
of are relatively recent.
The earliest known example of Albanian writing is from 1462.
And the first Albanian book was written in 1555 efforts to standardize
the literary language,
both in orthography and language forms only began in the early 20th century and
the common standard wasn't accepted everywhere until the second half of the 20th
century, as late as 1968 in Kosovo,
the standard that came to predominate was based on the task dialect though.
It contains elements of the other major dialect as well.
Gig task and gig are roughly divided by the [inaudible] river
with varieties of task being spoken in Southern Albania, parts of Italy, Greece,
and Turkey, and the gig being spoken in Kosovo, Northern Albania,
the Republic of North Macedonia and Montenegro,
both dialects have a number of sub dialects,
and there is a transitional dialect in central Albania.
What's Albanian like let's look at some basic words and to start,
and since it's kind of hard to find Albanian speakers to help with this video,
I'm just going to use the Google translate voice. Let's check it out.
Yes.
On second thought. I think I'll find a native speaker. Hello.
Gimme notice that this letter is pronounced as Chuck. Good morning.
Yes. Good is Mia and morning is Jess.
This letter represents a Schwab sound and you'll see this a lot in Albanian,
but notice that it's reduced and almost not heard at the end of words, Mia,
and notice that this diagraph is pronounced as a palatal jaw,
similar to Jeff, except that the tongue is retracted towards the palette.
Joe is represented by the diagraph X H Albanian has a number of diagraphs
combinations of two letters that represent a single consonant sound good
afternoon.
Mudita Dita means day. Good evening.
Member Ima [inaudible] means evening. And in Burma.
[Inaudible] actually means last night,
[inaudible] Bone voyage or have a nice trip.
Broke Dunbar in the word meaner.
You heard an R sound, which was an alveolar or post alveolar,
approximate similar to the R sound in North American English.
That sound is written with a single R in the word rogue.
We can see that the double R represents a trill in Albanian called the police.
[inaudible] notice that Albanian has a thud sound represented by T H.
It also has a voice.
The sound represented by D H it's one of a small number of
Indo-European languages that has those sounds go away.
Notice that the diagraph Z H represents the sound like the French J
sound. What's your name? [inaudible] informal speech.
And [inaudible] in informal speech.
The letter Q represents the sound cha like jaw,
but with the tongue retracted towards the palate, my name.
Is [inaudible].
Now let's examine a few features of the language. Now, in cases,
there are five known cases in Albania. Nominative accusative, dative,
genitive, and ablative evocative case also exists,
but isn't very common nouns have endings that show the case of the note.
Those endings are also different for singular and plural,
as well as definite and indefinite. So the endings function,
not only as case markers, but also as markers of definiteness,
the indefinite singular forms also have an indefinite article before the noun,
which also means one and the indefinite plural forms can also be proceeded by
DISA a word,
meaning some the case declensions are different for masculine nouns and feminine
nouns. And there are some variations within both masculine and feminine,
depending on the sound at the end of the word, adjectives,
adjectives come after the noun. For example,
meaning the good boy and [inaudible] meaning the good girl,
adjective endings don't change very much. They're usually the same,
except for the feminine plural form,
which ends in ah [inaudible]. But they are proceeded by linking articles, that
show case
gender number and definiteness it's worth noting that adjectives can be attributive meaning they come right after the
noun
, or they can be predicative meaning they come after a linking verb in Albanian, in the plural definite form. The adjectives have different linking articles depending on whether the adjective is attributive or predicative for example, the good.
Visa MENA and the girls are good vies at the end to me. Yeah.
Yeah. Notice here at the verb,
meaning to be a predicates of adjective comes after a linking verb,
whereas an attributive adjective comes right after the noun.
Verbs verbs are one of the most complex things about Albania,
because there are many moods that are used together with tenses.
Moods are verb forms that indicate the attitude of the speaker towards what is
being said. There are six moods indicative,
which expresses a fact or asks a question subjunctive,
which show is possibility optative which expresses a wish Admiral,
which expresses surprise or disagreement, conditional,
which expresses something dependent on a condition and imperative used for
commands or instructions.
The subjunctive and optative moods are closely related and both existed in prodo
window.
European Albanian is the only modern Indo-European language that maintains both
of them in parallel in other Indo-European languages. They either merged,
or one of them fell out of use. There are eight basic tenses in Albania,
which incorporate both tents and aspect together,
but not all of the tenses are used with each mood in the indicative mood.
There are eight tenses in the subjunctive mood.
There are four tenses in the admirals of mood,
four tenses in the optative mood, two tenses in the conditional mood,
two tenses and in the imperative mood, just one pronouns,
personal pronouns in Albania differ depending on case in the accusative and date
of cases, the personal pronouns are accompanied by short forms. In other words,
clinic pronouns that appear before the verb. For example.
Meaning I.
Saw him at the, is an accusative pronoun for the third person singular,
but it's accompanied by a clinic pronoun,
which goes before the verb note that this sentence could also.
Be since Albanian.
Is pro drop and the subject pronoun can be dropped because it's obvious from the
verb conjugation.
Oftentimes the full pronoun is left out and only the clinic pronoun is used.
So the sentence above could.
Also be, or.
The short forms also appear together with nouns in the accusative and date of
cases. For example.
And I followed the doctorate, meaning ever. I spoke to the doctor here, doctor.
Down in the date of case and the clinic pronoun.
He accompanies it appearing before the verb,
but they don't appear in every case when the object is in the date of case.
In other words, an indirect object,
the clinic pronoun is required when the object is in the accusative case though,
in other words, a direct object, the clinic pronoun is used in certain cases,
but not others.
The basic rule is that the accusative clinic pronoun must be used when the
accusative object. In other words,
the direct object is not the focus of the sentence while the clinic pronoun
can't be used. When the accusative object is the focus of the sentence.
For example.
[Inaudible].
The sentences both mean ever bought the dress. But in the second sentence,
the focus is on the dress. For example, answering the question,
which item did she buy?
So the clinic doesn't appear possessive adjectives.
There are also possessive adjectives in Albania, which follow the noun,
that's possessed and agree with it in case and gender. For example,
Bastian NNT meaning I saw his dog. This is the possessive adjective,
meaning his four nouns in the accusative case and this sentence.
She needed DA's tissue to her, meaning his.
Dog is ugly. This also means his,
but it's in the nominative case because the dog is the subject.
Also notice the different endings of the noun, meaning dog,
depending on its case, and notice the linking article before the adjective.
Also note that it's a predicative adjective and follows the linking verb.
It's the third person singular present form of the verb.
Meaning to be now let's focus on a couple more Albanian sentences and
see what we find. Here's a sentence.
Meaning the company president gave a promotion to his employees.
[Inaudible].
Word for word it's.
President company gave a raise in duty employee
his in this sentence, we see several examples of noun cases.
So let's focus on those for a minute. First, look at the phrase,
busy Dan Deckland Bernice.
The first noun is the definite singular nominative form of Missy.
Then the second now is the indefinite singular genitive form of company.
The preposition E meaning of is part of the genitive form.
The case forms for these two nouns are different because of their gender.
They see den is masculine and company is feminine.
Here.
Is the indefinite.
Singular accusative form of the now, which is the same as the nominative form.
This now is in the accusative case because it's the direct object of the verb.
Indefinite singular nouns are proceeded by an indefinite article,
which also means one it's followed by the preposition.
No meaning in then by the noun, the dura meaning duty.
This now is in the indefinite singular accusative form because of the
preposition that comes before it next,
the [inaudible] is the definite third person,
singular data form of the masculine noun who knowing yours it's data
because the employee is the indirect object of the verb.
And he is the clinic pronoun accompanying the date of now
it's worth pointing out that the word order in Albanian is flexible.
It would be perfectly fine to say this sentence this way. Instead.
Residential companies [inaudible] new ingredient or the dura.
Another sentence. This sentence means we want to buy some souvenirs.
[Inaudible].
Word for word it.
We want subjunctive particle by some souvenirs.
First we see that the nominative personal pronoun. Yeah.
Which means we can be dropped.
Doula is the first person plural present indicative form of the verb. Doula,
meaning want in English. The verb want is followed by the infinitive of a verb,
but Albanian has no infinitive form. The subjunctive form is used instead.
This is the subjunctive form of the verb.
BA meaning to buy is the subjunctive particle,
which proceeds the subjunctive form of the verb. For most subjects.
The subjunctive form is the same as the indicative,
except for the second person and third person singular, which are different.
The subjunctive is used after other modal verbs as well. Like do hurt,
meaning must and mooned. Meaning can finally,
the word souvenir is the plural indefinite accusative form of the nouns.
Linear Albanian is a fascinating language with some unique
features that make it stand out from other Indo-European languages.
And it also has some other features in common with other languages of the
Balkins because of the Balkin Sprott Puente,
an area in which all of the different languages of the Balkins influence each
other through contact in this video,
we've basically just scratched the surface of Albanian,
especially with regards to its rich verbal system of tenses and moods.
But if Albanian captures your imagination,
then you might want to check out these two courses,
colloquial Albanian the complete course for beginners and discovering Albanian.
One,
both courses are by Linda Monico and Hector Campos colloquial
Albanian seems more accessible to the casual learner while discovering Albanian.
It seems more thorough and made for serious learners.
The question of the day for native speakers of Albania,
do you speak a task dialect or a gig dialect?
How different are they and how well do you understand the other group of
dialects and for everyone else, what's your impression of Albania.
And after watching the video, leave your comments down below.
If you enjoyed this video,
then check out Lang focus on the various social media platforms like Facebook,
YouTube, Twitter. And,
and of course I want to say a very special thanks to all of my Patrion
supporters, especially these ones right here on the screen.
They are my top tier of Patrion supporters, many extra special,
thanks to them and to everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice day.